there is also breaking news from Hong
Kong police have fired tear gas this
morning to control tens of thousands of
protesters who converged on a rural town
where suspected gangsters attacked
demonstrators and commuters last weekend
rémi innocence Oh is in Hong Kong with
the latest chaos on the streets here in
Hong Kong riot police have been engaged
with pro-democracy protesters for the
past hour they are stationed right
behind me here and over this past time
there has been tear gas that's been
flying we ourselves were tear gas you
can also see things stone on the ground
tear gas canisters umbrellas as well as
water bottles but this gets to there the
reason of what's happening here
basically a week ago an angry mob of
people attacked innocent bystanders as
well as protesters at a nearby subway
station the police were slow to respond
and that's why people here are out in
force now these protesters have been
continually pushing these ride please
further and further back which is also
surprising in addition they're furious
at the bigger picture universal suffrage
something that they don't have they're
also asking demanding that their chief
executive Carrie Lam resign
ramie Inocencio CBS News Hong Kong